thank you everyone for
participating today in this great event
i'm going to be talking today about our
work one of our projects
uh th17 inducing vaccines for the
treatment ovarian cancer my name is
keith knudsen i'm a professor of
immunology and a professor of cancer
biology located at the mayo clinic in a
beautiful
downtown
jacksonville beach area
and uh my partners that are involved in
this are dr matt block he is an
associate professor at the
mayo clinic in rochester arizona and dr
martin cannon a professor of
microbiology and immunology at the
university of arkansas
and before i get started i just wanted
to preview a couple of
i'm going to have to start at the top at
that one because i hit the right wrong
button
so i'm going to go back to that one
before i get started just a couple of
conflicts of interest some of the
materials and vaccines that i'll be
talking about today have been licensed
to
companies that i'm involved with that
provide funding
or that i have ownership for example
marker therapeutics which has licensed
some of the vaccine technology
and chromic which is a licensee of some
of the technologies that we use to
produce our dendritic cells
today i will focus on
the
challenges of combating ovarian cancer
ovarian cancer is relatively rare
disease
worldwide there is approximately 239
000 cases per year it's very deadly so
the vast majority of people that are
diagnosed with ovarian cancer
die as a result of that disease we
estimate worldwide there's about 152 000
deaths per year
a small fraction of those are in the u.s
22 000 cases and 14 000 case or deaths
per year
and as you can see from the death to
case ratio
the mortality
is very high and that's due to the fact
that ovarian cancer is typically
diagnosed in its most
advanced stages
current therapies include chemotherapy
and surgical resection and oftentimes
the individuals
in about 85 percent of the cases that
are diagnosed with ovarian cancer
ultimately relapse and then
treatment goes on from there um and
after several treatments typically uh
death ensues in these patients
so our current uh strategies for
treating ovarian cancer are not that
effective in in terms of preventing
death although they can prolong the life
of the individual so there's a continued
need to
develop new therapies that can fight
ovarian cancer and so certainly one of
the most important areas that is being
evaluated in the field of oncology today
is the development of immune-based
therapies
like other cancers in ovarian cancer
we've known now for
several decades that
the immune system has a role in
the natural outcome of disease this is a
study that was published in
2003 from dr
zhang and and kenejo garcia with dr
kukos at the university of pennsylvania
where they analyzed
several hundred
specimens from ovarian cancer patients
for the infiltration of immune effectors
specifically focusing on t cells finding
that those individuals that had uh
evidence of t cell infiltration into
their tumor had improved
disease-free survival and so i'm not
going to go into
an extensive
overview of what the
immune system is but just to point out
that there are two arms to the immune
system the innate and the adaptive
immune arm
the adaptive immune arm is where uh t
cells come from and where b cells and
antibodies come from and beyond that
there is it's also known that the immune
system can differentiate depending on
the type of insult whether it's a you
know cancer
or a virus or bacteria or something like
that i like to think of it as there's
multiple flavors of the immune response
and some of these are important in
eradicating cancer and some of those
have a pathologic role in cancer so for
example regulatory t cells
are a component of the adaptive immune
response
and are known to regulate the immune
response to
an antigenic insult by suppressing or
limiting the clonal expansion of the
immune response and also play a role in
protecting
ovarian cancers as well as a wide
variety of other cancers from the immune
response in fact in ovarian cancer there
are a number of different mechanisms
which have been identified by our group
and other groups throughout the last
couple of decades
that clearly demonstrate that
the ovarian cancers can
attract in a number of different cell
types that can block an effective
anti-tumor
immune response i had already mentioned
that
regulatory t cells were a main component
of that immune response in fact this is
a diagram here
showing
the
staining of a tissue section for
regulatory t cells the combination of
cd4 cd25 and fox p3 and as you can see
here you can see these
little cells that
are stained blue in the nucleus those
are the regulatory t cells they
constitute about one third of the total
infiltrating cd4 population the cd4
population
being the dominant
t cell infil infiltrate in ovarian
cancer so with that said
ovarian cancer is
is
targeted by the immune system but also
it induces local tolerance that prevents
the immune system uh from attacking it
as a result of that our strategy has
been to develop
strategies to boost host immune defenses
to prevent disease
following
standard conventional therapies like
surgery and chemotherapy so there's
windows of opportunity for many cancers
as well as ovarian cancer in which
following a standard surgery and
chemotherapy that one could think about
using strategies to boost the immune
response in our case we've been
interested in the development of
vaccines to boost
t cells in antibody responses
hopefully to ultimately prevent
recurrence and it seems to be an
approach that
will ultimately be found to be
successful so when we think about the
development of
vaccines we think about well what are we
going to target and
how are we going to formulate that into
a vaccine so there are a number of
different approaches that people are
using to develop cancer vaccines one
certainly is the targeting of microbial
derived antigens that may be important
in cancers such as head and neck cancer
or cervical cancer but there's no
microbial etiologic agents associated
with ovarian cancer so we have to turn
to
other antigens one
source of antigens could be mutated
mutation derived neoantigens which are
present one of the problems with
targeting neoantigens or
neoantigens that are derived from
mutations is that they're personalized
for each individual patient
as
mutation derived neoantigens are often
found to be
only in a you know single tumor or
rarely in a few individuals
and most of them are are personal
we've been interested in in developing
vaccines based on over expressed cell
proteins as a source of what we call
tumor subdominant neoantigens and this
is based on work that goes back into
the
1980s and 1990s from
several pioneering
immunologists that
uh demonstrated long ago that your body
develops tolerance against subdominate
excuse me against dominant epitopes that
are presented on
self mhc either class 1 or class 2
molecules
and importantly in cancers over
expression can lead to
what we call or what we term
subdominant neo antigens and that's
shown in this figure here where dominant
antigens are shown in blue and
subdominant antigens are shown in red so
as overexpression occurs aberrant
processing aberrant tumor
cell localization occurs and that
results in the presentation of unusual
epitopes derived from other parts of the
protein
that is over
expressed so using a variety of
different approaches
including bioinformatics
mhc binding and t-cell activation assays
as well as the assessment of natural
pre-existent immunity
in individuals we can formulate vaccines
and we've been interested in several
different antigens and one in particular
for ovarian cancer and antigen folate
receptor alpha is over expressed in
about 95 percent of cases
that we see stage
typically stage
three and stage four high grade serous
ovarian cancer and to formulate a
vaccine we use bioinformatics and we
determine
using bioinformatics the
epitopes that would be bound to mhc
class 2 molecules so we're very much
interested as opposed to
identifying cd8 t-cell inducing vaccines
cd4
t-cell-inducing vaccines due to the
central role of cd4s in uh developing
immune responses
they're as as many of you know
involved in in orchestrating the
development of antibodies orchestrating
the development of macrophage driven or
nk cell driven immune responses as well
as cd8 t cell responses so our focus has
been on identifying mhc class 2 or hla
class ii binding epitopes that we can
formulate and particularly interested in
identifying those in which an existing t
cell repertoire is available so in this
rather simplified overview of that
strategy we use bioinformatics and we
predict epitopes along the continuum of
folate receptor alpha and then we
identify which of those epitopes
actually binds to mhc class ii molecules
and then we select out of those which
bind to multiple mhc class 2 molecules
that we would see in the population
that's at risk for recurrence of ovarian
cancer and then conduct t cell
activation assays and verify using
natural pre-existent immunity type
assays
to determine
those epitopes that could be formulated
in the vaccine so in this particular
case we identified several different
epitopes and the ones shown in red that
are the ones that we ultimately selected
as being
potential subdominant neo antigens that
are expressed as a result of
overexpression of folate receptor in the
tumor microenvironment as well as in the
regional lymph nodes and we formulated
this vaccine and compounded it with
gmcsf and adjuvant and initially
delivered it now going on about 10 years
ago
to patients with breast and ovarian
cancer to demonstrate number one in a
phase one clinical trial that we could
specifically target these subdominant
neo antigens
in a vaccine
safely in individuals and generate
immune responses so the upper graph
shows the development of immunity pre
and post to the vaccine
components fr 30 56
76 113 and 238 following immunization
over the course of six months and we see
that we could
also detect immunity to these
epitopes in follow-up
anywhere between 12 and 18 months in
individuals and while i don't have
the slide here that shows the safety
analysis in general immunizing in this
fashion using subdominant neoantigens is
a
very safe approach and typically the
only adverse events that we see
associated with vaccination
include what you would see with other
vaccines
such as skin site
reactions or general fatigue
and possibly even fever
so with that said uh after we conducted
that clinical trial we became interested
in the study that was published by
weiping zoo from the university of
michigan and followed on by a couple of
other investigative groups
that had demonstrated that il-17 was
associated with improved survival in
ovarian cancer and that's shown on the
left-hand slide here individuals with
high levels of il-17 in their tumor
micro environment as opposed to low
tend to have much better survival
recurrence-free survival than those
individuals that had lower levels and
what's important is that we saw also
that
or the data showed also that individuals
with high levels of th17 tended to have
much reduced levels of regulatory t
cells thus they had less immune
suppressive potential in their tumor
microenvironment so if we could develop
vaccines that not only targeted
subdominant epitopes
but also generated
il-17 or th17 responses
we hypothesized that we could
potentially protect individuals from
relapse following conventional therapies
but to do that we had to figure out a
solution for being able to specifically
induce the
th17 t-cell subset following vaccination
so at that time
back in the early 2010s we
came across
dr martin cannon's studies in which he
was looking at the modulation of p-38
map kinase and dendritic cells
along with il-15 co-stimulation
finding that if you use that approach
strictly in in vitro assays he could
induce il-17 producing t cells and thus
we thought there was an opportunity for
us to incorporate the recipe
that he developed into a clinical recipe
for
developing dendritic cells that induced
th17 t cells and ultimately following
pulsing of those dendritic cells to
induce th17 tail
th17t cells that were specific
for
the folate receptor alpha
and therefore we came up with a
cocktail that we moved clinically this
is data
actually showing uh from uh preclinical
mouse studies in which il-15
co-stimulation of np-38
map kinase inhibition
suppressed il-12 and il-10 and that
favored the generation of th17 i'm not
going to go into all of the data
but how it did that was
by suppressing the il-12 driven th1
t-cell component and allowing the
development of th17
due to the fact that it suppressed those
specific uh cytokines such as style 12
while at the same time
maintaining importance cytokines such as
il-6 il-1 alpha or excuse me il-1 beta
and tgf beta which are important to the
development of th17
t-cell effectors so then we designed a
clinical trial
and worked with
the mayo clinic
ovarian cancer spore as well as
benefactors to come up with a
funding for a phase one clinical trial
in 19 patients with the primary goal
of looking at safety and immunogenicity
of a special th17 inducing dendritic
cell vaccine that can induce th17 t
cells specific for
the folate receptor alpha and that
clinical trial um is now completed and
was published in in nature
communications in 2020 uh just briefly
an overview individuals
were given a leukopheresis at
registration and we produced dendritic
cells pulsed with the folate receptor
peptides and ultimately immunize those
individuals five
times
every three weeks followed by boosters
periodically and then followed those
individuals up for
a couple of years
following the initiation of vaccines so
i'm going to touch on just some of that
data
demonstrating that we were able to
accomplish the goal of inducing th17
t cell effectors in these individuals
and this is shown here kind of in a
nutshell
looking at the mean levels of antigen
specific not only th17 but also th1
cells specific for each of the epitopes
that were in the vaccine as well as the
response to the native folate receptor
alpha including controls tetanus toxin
and cyclin d1 as you can appreciate on
the left side
we saw
an escalation in the
levels of th1t cells that's something
that we didn't expect
quite as high as we saw in the previous
clinical trials but importantly we saw
the ability of the vaccine to induce
th17
t cells as well so
we we achieved our primary goal of being
able to induce th17
and
we also found due to the
rather degenerate nature of the epitopes
that we use that we were able to
generate immune responses th1 and th17
in the vast majority
of individuals
and interestingly enough and something
that we didn't see with just peptide
vaccine alone is that about half of the
patients responded to the dendritic cell
vaccine with peptide specific antibodies
so you would think that if we pulse
these
epitopes on dendritic cells that we
would generate predominantly uh t you
know t cell responses but that wasn't
the case we saw
for at least uh uh three or four of the
peptides uh
good evidence of the generation of
antibody responses uh in fact the
generation of these antibody responses
led to about 50 percent of individuals
developing antibodies that could
recognize
a folate receptor expression
at the cell surface and when we did an
analysis looking at the bottom right
hand graphs to see if those peptides
were or excuse me those antibodies were
specific for peptides we found indeed
that they were so antibodies were being
generated
against the epitopes that were being
presented by the
dendritic cells interestingly enough but
most importantly out of all of this we
had the opportunity to follow up the
patients
for a couple of years after the
beginning of vaccination as i had
mentioned
and this data is uh was was relatively
shocking to us that while we would have
expected you know perhaps 85 percent of
patients to have relapsed in 24
months following enrollment on study we
in fact found that about 40 percent of
the patients uh appeared to have been
cured going out to about 50 or 60 months
in fact that still holds
even you know many months after the
initial publication and like we found
with our
previous peptide vaccine
there were minimal adverse events
injection site reactions were the most
common adverse event there was some pain
associated with uh vaccination after the
vaccinations were given but in general
the
uh adverse events were typically grade
one and grade two and were very uh
transient uh in nature
immunity was also associated with uh
recurrence when i looked at those
individuals that had no recurrence
versus those that did have recurrence we
could see that both the th1 immune
response and the antibody response but
interestingly not the il-17 response
were associated with improved survival
indicating that there was some
interactions or some coordination
amongst all of these immune effectors in
the tumor microenvironment to eradicate
disease and also importantly we found
that immunity was persistent so looking
at those patients that didn't recur long
uh
after a long time after the ending of
vaccine
at two years
you could see that they still maintained
high levels of th1t cells il17 or th17 t
cells as well as antibodies so a very
impressive outcome uh with this
particular vaccine and we also observed
that the antibodies
were
[Music]
able to induce antibody dependent
cellular cytotoxicity which was also
associated with recurrence-free
survival
as well so it looked to us that there
was a
coordinated immune response that
involved many different types of immune
effectors that were generated with this
vaccine that could possibly be
contributing to
the destruction
of the tumor and we also looked in those
individuals that had disease recurrence
and found despite the fact that they had
recurrence that there was some
important changes now on one hand we
didn't see any evidence of immunoediting
so when we generated immunity against
the folate receptor alpha we had thought
you know perhaps that those patients
that did recur would uh
recurs with uh
antigen loss variants we didn't see any
evidence of that in the first
left-hand slide or excuse me graph in
which we
plotted out the flight receptor
expression based on h score we didn't
see any evidence of infiltration of cd8
t cells into the tumor microenvironment
so cda t cells had been previously found
to be associated with disease recurrence
so this is interesting because in our
mouse studies which i'll show on the
next slide we saw no evidence of any
involvement of cd8 t cells in fact the
the
vaccine
seems to be protective and and dependent
exclusively on cd4 t cells whereas what
we did see is that the induction of of
th17 in those patients that did receive
vaccine and recurred the
down regulation of regulatory t cells as
we would have expected based on this
reciprocal a relationship that was
already observed in prior studies with
th17 and regulatory t cells and those
tumors that
did relapse following vaccination all
had high levels of pdl-1
many of them had very low levels prior
to the administration of vaccine
indicating that there was an active
immune response going on in the tumor
microenvironment and this is the data
from the mirroring model in which we
recapitulate the
survival that we see in individuals
shown in the upper
left-hand
graph is a comparison between
antigen-pulsed conventional dendritic
cells and antigen pulse th17 dc shown in
the blue
bar which demonstrates that this type of
vaccine approaches is superior to that
than conventional disease but most
importantly in the middle
graph on the top there is a
demonstration that the inclusion of
anti-cd4 which depletes cd4 t cells
during the course of immunization
completely reversed the protective
effect of the vaccine whereas anti-cd8
had no impact and specifically we only
were able to detect il-17 in the
peritoneal cavities of mice with
ovarian cancer with the th17 vaccine
demonstrating the specific induction
with this approach of il-15
co-stimulation and p-38 map kinase
inhibition and importantly also those
tumors
that did relapse in these or that did
recur in these individuals were
infiltrated with higher levels of cd4 t
cells as opposed to cda t cells
demonstrating to us that the primary
adaptive immune mechanisms that were
generated following the vaccination
where cd8 t cells excuse me cd4 t cell
responses as well as antibody responses
and probably a coordinated effort among
different subsets of t cells as well as
with antibodies and ultimately we think
myeloid effectors in the tumor
microenvironment such as macrophages
played a role in eradication of the
tumor based on our mouse modeling
experiments
which i do not have time to present
today
and based on all of this we
are moving forward with a phase two uh
trial um mc1963
at the mayo clinic in which we will test
this vaccine
in a randomized placebo-controlled
clinical trial that aims to enroll a
total of 78 patients two-thirds of those
patients will be randomized to arm one
and we'll see receive the vaccine
in much the same manner that they
received in the phase one clinical trial
with the ultimate goal of determining
whether or not as we would suspect that
it prevents relapse in individuals and
so that trial is set to be activated
within the next year it's part of the
mayo clinic ovarian cancer spore
specific aim one is to look at
progression-free survival
specific aim2 to
understand the types of immune responses
and give a better handle on why patients
are in some cases resistant
to the vaccine-induced
t cell and antibody responses and then
follow that on with more mechanistic
studies in mouse models to help us try
to understand
better
what is
the primary mechanisms by which the
tumor is eradicated following
immunization
there are also opportunities to
potentially give this in combination
with immune checkpoint blockade we found
in our prior studies that aisle 10
is
released
in the tumor microenvironment at very
high levels following
the
treatment with
isle
anti-pd1 monotherapy
and il-10 suppresses the generation of
immune responses making
these particular tumors resistant to
anti-pd1 therapy and what we found with
vaccine in the far right hand graph is
that
the vaccination prevented the ielts the
anti-pd1 induced aisle
10 release into the tumor micro
environment and collaborated with the
vaccine to provide
superior protection in in these mice
that have been challenged with ovarian
cancer ongoing research continues but
what we think is happening is a complex
set of events that involves as i had
mentioned exclusively cd4 t cells
and antibodies along with
macrophages and other myeloid cells that
migrate into the tumor microenvironment
one dominant myeloid cell is the
eosinophils so th17 we think coordinates
the activity through elaboration of a
wide variety of different
substances that
would support the generation of
macrophages and eosinophils as well as
amplified the effects of
th2 immune effectors which we've
observed in the mouse models as well as
th1 effectors leading to a coordinated
anti-tumor immune response so in
conclusion we think that
in
ovarian cancer there are opportunities
windows of opportunity to boost
host immune defenses following
conventional treatment with
surgery and chemotherapy
to
boost um t cells and antibodies that
could ultimately protect individuals
from uh recurring and increased survival
certainly the survival data uh from our
uh trial that we just published in uh
nature communications that i presented
today would indicate that at least in in
a subset of individuals we are having an
impact in preventing disease rev
recurrence possibly even curing these
patients
many of them are are now outside of
standard monitoring for ovarian cancer
recurrence
and
demonstrating
good health and a strong
anti-tumor immune response
th17 immunity in the tumor
immune micro environment dissociates
as i had previously mentioned with
better outcome in patients with ovarian
cancer and that has represented an
opportunity for us to try to think of
ways to improve that
with vaccines there are other potential
opportunities for example car t cell
therapy
may be an attractive approach to
generating that as well vaccines can be
developed
that target
aberrantly expressed proteins and folate
receptor alpha is a great example in
ovarian cancer that's highly
overexpressed
and plays a role in the biologic
activity and aggressiveness of ovarian
cancer and is potentially targeted due
to its aberrant expression and cell
localization that ultimately results in
the presentation of novel subdominant
neo antigens to which the immune system
has never responded or even seen before
to which we can generate immunity and
what we know from our studies is that
th17 tsa or vaccines can induce durable
poly functional immune responses in ned
patients despite the fact that these
patients have been treated for their
cancer with aggressive chemotherapies
they can still induce these immune
responses that appear to be helpful in
prolonging survival and as i had
mentioned our future directions are to
continue with our randomized phase 2
clinical trial to
support the
potential
licensing of this applica
this particular vaccine application in
patients with ovarian cancer following
conventional therapy
but also
an interest in in using it to
test in combination with immune
checkpoint blockade which hasn't been
very effective in patients with ovarian
cancer and other cancers as well
and our future directions will also
focus on mechanisms of therapeutic
activity and resistance and we're
particularly interested in why those
individuals that did not
that responded the vaccine but did not
show any evidence of protection
following vaccination
were indeed resistant and if we can
identify those mechanisms perhaps we can
you know come up with ways that we can
tweak the vaccine
to support better outcomes in those
patients that are resistant we're
looking at a number of different
mechanisms so i'll conclude now
with
acknowledgements
of uh
this
work wasn't possible
without the input from many many people
at the mayo clinic and other
institutions as well and a special
thanks to
dr kim calley dr matt block
martin cannon from the university of
arkansas and the individuals that help
produce the gmp great dendritic cells dr
alan dies and michael gustafson as well
as a number of other physicians in the
environment at mayo clinic that
helped enroll the patients in this
clinical trial and grant support from
many individuals particularly
the initiating grant support from the
schultz family foundation
uh who provided
funding for the initial clinical trial
to get this into uh the first cohort of
individuals as well as a company tap
immune now marker therapeutics which i
commented on
at the beginning of the talk as
licensing the
epitope technology from us as well as
a variety of different grants from the
national cancer institute
as well as private foundations such as
mocha and the anderson foundation
and with that i would like to again uh
thank you uh for
participating in the meeting and
listening to our
presentation of our study thank you very
much